[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand vous me regardez qu'est ce qui
vous vient à l'esprit
je pense pas que chasseuse soit le mot
que vous ayez en tête c'est prend le
mans pau ce qu'on imaginait une fille
qui a grandi sur le plateau montréal
puis un bac en droit mais pour être
honnête c'est parce que j'imagine et moi
non plus je connais près de l'océan et
puis pour tout vous dire j'ai eu une
peur bleue de l'eau toute ma vie ça
s'est pas améliorée quand j'ai failli me
noyer à l'âge de 14 ans je m'appelle
valentine tabac
j'ai 32 ans et je suis pêcheur
professionnel au harpon avant j'attrape
ma propre nourriture
j'ai travaillé à l'ombre en finances
pendant six ans non j'ai toujours acheté
mon poisson l'épicerie sont vraiment
trop réfléchir
j'ai toujours eu accès à de l'argent et
à des épiceries donc pourquoi est-ce que
j'ai décidé de risquer ma vie afin
d'attraper ma propre nourriture
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai décidé de faire
un retour aux sources
alors de là qu'est la technologie me
donne accès à tout ce que je toute
l'année au bout de mes doigts
imaginez si vous faisiez un retour aux
sources
à quoi ressemblerait votre vie quel sera
l'impact sur votre cotiser comment
est-ce que salim flux en frais votre
vision du monde c'est difficile à
imaginer
laissez moi vous raconter mon retour aux
sources
je me suis jamais vraiment questionné
sur la manière dont ma nourriture était
passé de la ferme ou de l'océan à
l'épicerie au coin de chez moi la
plupart des gens en parlent pas et n'y
pense pas et puis c'est normal avec
notre mode de vie effréné nos factures à
payer mais en vêtements je pense que ça
plaît à tout le monde
nous on a une conscience tranquille
et puis les compagnies font plus
d'argent donc on n on a un esprit qui
est dépourvu de tout questionnement
dérangeant auxquelles on n'a pas le
temps de penser de toute façon donc
alors que j'ai fait l'autruche pendant
toutes ces années la technologie elle
est le continuer d'avancer
on ne fait des fermes plus grosses avec
plus d'animaux qu'on a battu plus jeunes
ou qu'on a gavé de produits chimiques
les océans se sont vidés et sont devenus
de plus en plus polluée donc l'histoire
suivi son cours dans le silence le plus
absolu
les compagnies se sont réjouis de mon
manque de connexion avec ma nourriture
alors que moi je me réjouissais de mon
steak et de mon sushi prochain mais le
moins on en parle le mieux notre
conscience se portent les personnes qui
ont envie de passer de passer à la pompe
vache qui a été exécuté pendant qu'ils
mangeront hamburger ce c'est très normal
jeudi par une façon pour une île
l'atmosphère dans un sourire le jour où
j'ai attrapé mon premier poisson
j'ai compris j'ai compris ma place dans
l'écosystème et j'ai compris qu'en tant
qu en tant qu'être humain on n'était pas
au dessus mais bien en plein de bain ce
qui fait que l'humain se conscientisent
c'est la proximité
les personnes qui pensent au cancer la
rétine avant quelqu'un de proche de qui
en souffrent la plupart des fondations
ont été créées par des gens qui ont été
touchés personnellement par la cause en
question
et puis pour les océans c'est la même
chose
les personnes qui y a personne qui va
s'en préoccuper jusqu'au jour où sous
votre cogné la tête sur une bouteille de
plastique en faisant 1 h du matin ou que
tu vois trébuché sur un pneu en faisant
marche au tapage préféré à cayo coco ou
que
poisson habituel devient exorbitant à
l'épicerie le jour où j'ai vu un mini
frigo dans le fond de l'eau au beau
milieu de nulle part dans les bahamas
j'ai compris qu'il y avait quelque chose
qui n'allait vraiment pas le jour où
j'ai attrapé mon premier poisson tous eu
à changer
et puis ce lien de proximité la changer
mes habitudes de consommation parce que
d'enfants on se trouve bien teuf avec
d'autres technologies met dans l'eau on
n'est pas l'espèce la plus dominante
loin de l'offre ça il faut jamais
l'oublier mais c'est un peu ce qui m'a
fait tomber en amour avec l'océan parce
que quand tu es dans l'eau tu apprends
prendre ta place je t'apprends un
respecter ce qui est autour de toi que
tu au plombier ou soit pdg d'une grosse
compagnie le requin lui fera pas la
différence
d'ailleurs les trois faux je me suis
personnellement attaqué par un requin si
jamais l'argent qui m'a sauvé donc on
vers la chaîne alimentaire depuis des
milliers d'années grâce à notre cerveau
la révolution cognitive qui était un
cadeau du ciel est un cadeau empoisonné
nous ont menés à détacher de plus en
plus de notre habitat naturel
tout ce afin de créer un cocon de
confort qui a été propulsée par
l'avancement de la technologie
depuis des milliers d'années la
technologie et l'innovation sont devenus
nos meilleurs amis et nos pires ennemis
l'évolution beaucoup trop rapide de
l'humain nous amener un peu à nous
détacher de ce qu'ils aiment autour de
nous et puis j'imagine que vous vous
demandez moi le gpat en aller pêcher la
truite la fin de semaine
vous avez bien raison parce qu'il serait
bien d'illusoires de penser qu' on
pourrait tous se nourrir de chasse et de
pêche
par contre je crois fortement que
l'avancement de la technologie et
l'innovation passe par une connexion
avec qui nous sommes
on ne peut pas évoluer sans comprendre
exactement qui on est et l'environnement
dans lequel on vit les enjeux
écologiques économiques et sociaux
passés ont tous quelque chose à nous
apprendre
donc on vit dans un monde où
l'avancement de la technologie et le
détachement à l'hôtel à la nature se
fait au détriment de notre bonheur
personnel
mon désir de changer de vie et de
trouver un sens à mon existence avait
rien de surprenant je trouvais ma vie
non seulement ennuyante
mais dépourvu de sens aussi et puis si
on trouve que si la technologie est le
manque de proximité avec notre entourage
affecte notre environnement ce nous
applique également nous en tant
qu'humain est ce que quelqu'un réussit
déjà souffert d'une crise d'anxiété
moi j'ai ma première à 18 ans dans le
métro j'étais l'agoraphobie ça c'est la
peur des lieux publics et des foules
mais pourtant il y avait rien dans mon
entourage qui présentait un réel danger
c'est pas comme si j'avais pas de faire
piétiner par un dinosaure en allant
cueillir des framboises parce que j'en
avais besoin pour survivre
j'avais peur j'avais peur de rien en
fait
mais dix ans plus tard quand je me suis
retrouvé face à un requin j'ai paniqué
pourquoi malgré son évolution
l'être humain garde ses instincts s'est
inscrit dans son adn
et puis ce jeu les réaliser en allant
chasser sous l'eau quand on regarde et
qu'on analyse mon passé on peut pas
percevoir mon instinct de chasseur
skieuses pourtant il est bien là inscrit
dans mon adn est entièrement relié à mon
bonheur
bon malgré ma personnalité anxieuse je
peux au beau milieu de l'océan traquer
une proie pendant des heures je peut
repousser un requin de trois mètres tout
en gardant mon calme
parce que dans ces moments là j'ai agi
par instinct et je reconnais qu avec qui
je suis tout ça en oubliant le stress
provoqué par la technologie et
l'instantanéité de la société moderne
donc s'y prendre du recul peut sembler
régresser fo sud plusieurs il peut
s'avérer cruciale afin de trouver notre
bonheur est de connecter avec notre
environnement
quand j'ai fait mon retour aux sources
mon niveau de bonheur augmenté il est
impératif de comprendre qui nous sommes
en tant qu'humain et surtout
l'environnement dans lequel on vit est
ce que ça veut dire qu'on devrait
retourner à l'aube à l'âge de pierre
bien sûr que non mais est ce que ça veut
dire qu'on doit continuer de manger des
fraises en hiver et boire de l'eau de
coco à chicoutimi sans se poser de
questions non plus ça veut dire qu'il
faut qu'on utilise le pouvoir et les
ressources qu'on a
afin de connecter avec la planète et de
se conscientiser sur non seulement qu'
on est en tant qu'humain mais en tant
qu'homo sapiens est ce que nous vivons
tourné au désastre si on se connecte
plus avec notre avec la nature bien sûr
que non j'avais tout ce dont j'ai
toujours rêvé
j'avais une belle maison j'avais une
voiture de luxe de l'année et puis j'ai
un travail satisfaisant
donc oui quand j'ai tout laissé tomber
j'ai perdu des choses dans ma vie mais
ce que j'ai gagné en étant projet ma
nourriture et de la nature valley tout
l'or du monde
donc quand j'ai fait mon retour aux
sources
j'ai découvert un monde où ma nourriture
était meilleur que jamais où le contact
humain était crucial
où mes limites mentales et physiques
étaient beaucoup plus loin que ce que je
m'imaginais et où le monde autour de moi
et ma vie prenait finalement sens je me
suis isolé l'enfant du bois mais j'ai
pas non plus renier la technologie
quand je paye j'utilise un fusil un
fusil de chasse et une montre de plongée
sophistiqué que je suis bien contente
d'avoir d'ailleurs par exemple j'ai
compris ma place dans l'écosystème et j
ai appris à vivre avec ce qu'il y avait
autour de moi tout en respectant et non
en pensant que j'étais au dessus parce
qu'avant c'est ne veut pas dire de le
faire au détriment de la planète mais
bien en harmonie avec elle est en
harmonie avec qui nous sommes dans notre
adn des homo sapiens mais je peux vous
cacher mon retour aux sources c'est fait
par hasard j'ai fait une rencontre
improbable dans un avion avec quelqu'un
qui me présenter effet découvert une
activité dont j'avais jamais entendu
parler avant la chasse sous marine
donc une seule rencontre que changé le
cours de ma vie et vous à quoi
ressemblerait votre vie si vous prenez
du recul
imaginez si une seule découverte changer
complètement qui vous êtes
imaginez comment salines fluent serait
votre vision du monde imaginé
[Applaudissements]